翻訳: Machiko Takahashi
校正: Maki Sugimoto
みなさん こんにちは
今日は「まだ見ぬ生涯の友と生きる」
と題しまして
インターネット上のシニアの交流サイト
「メロウ倶楽部」の活動について
お話をさせて頂きたいと思います
その前に自己紹介をさせてください
1935年4月生まれで 今81歳です
高校を卒業してから定年まで
銀行に勤めておりました
定年後は自宅で
母の介護をしておりまして
ネットに親しむようになったのは
その頃からです
10年経って母は
100歳で亡くなりました
しかし介護の生活も
ネットのおかげで 友達もでき
情報もそれまでに比べて
豊かになったので
何か他の方よりも
楽しい介護ライフが
送れたのではないかと思いました
ならばこの介護ライフや
シニアライフには
ICTというのが役に立つのではないか
これを皆様に知って頂きたいと
最近は思っております
まず10年前から自宅で
パソコン教室を
始めております
週に２回ですけれども
ここではただ単に
操作手順みたいなのを
お教えするだけではなくて
すごい勢いで進歩し変化し続けている
ICTの最先端につきましても
例えばビッグデータとかIoTとか
人工知能なんかにつきましても
私の知っている範囲で
皆さんにもお知らせするようにしています
それからネット上の何か
新しい教材をということで
考案したものが「エクセル・アート」と称しまして
早く言えばセルとか罫線を
塗りつぶしたりして
デザインを考えていくというものです
シニアの方は大体
手芸みたいなものが
好きなものですから
こういうことは
とっても楽しんで下さって
これで兎角
年寄りに敬遠されがちな
エクセルというものが
馴染んで頂ければいいなぁと
そんな風に思っております
なんでエクセルかと言いますと
エクセルと言うのは
コンピュータの操作の基本について
理解できるソフトだと
思うからです
そしてそれをさらに3D化することで
まだ一層楽しみが増します
この3D化もマイクロソフトの
ウィンドウズのおまけソフトで
3Dビルダーとういのがあるのですが
それで作って格別
費用とか難しいこともなく
楽しめております
また自分の考案したデザインで
身の回りの例えばバッグとか
ブックカバーとか うちわとか
色々なものに応用して
楽しむことができます
そしてエクセルアートの他にも
このような私だけの
たった一つのペンダント等も
3Dプリンタを使って
楽しんでおります
手作りのものにこだわると
言いますのは
やはり今 一部のスマホユーザーなんかが
いわゆる大量消費社会の波に
そのまま流されていく方が
多いのですけれども
それもいいのですけれども
たまには何か私だけのものを
考案するのも
せっかく人間なんですから
人間が主人公になって
何か作るのがいいなあ
ということでやっております
その他 360度カメラも
楽しいですし
またタブレットの
楽器アプリを使って
楽器の独奏や合奏をするのも
楽しいのです
そういう楽しみ以外に
その日常の中からでてきた
シニアの方の困った情報を
「どうもここが使い勝手が悪い」
「シニアには使いにくい」とか
そんな情報について
お役所とかメーカーの方に
お取り次ぎする
ささやかですけど
そんな事もやらせて頂いています
それで私が一番大事に
思っていることは
メロウ倶楽部のことなんです
メロウ倶楽部の世話役という仕事が
一番自分にとって大切なミッションなんです
とういいますのは私は
20年間メロウ倶楽部に育てられ
メロウ倶楽部からただ単に
ICT技術だけではなく
もっと広い世界を教えてもらって
さらに生涯の本当のいいお友達に
沢山出会うことができたからです
それと もうひとつ
メロウ倶楽部はシニアが
自分達の知恵と力で
シニアにとって相応しい
インターネットの交流サイトを
構築しているところが
気に入っています
メロウ倶楽部は
北は北海道から
南は鹿児島まで
さらにアメリカ フィリピン
台湾 スペイン等に
あちこちバラバラに
会員さんがいて
約300人なんですけど
その中にはまだ一度も
会ったことない人も沢山います
年齢的には70歳以上の方が
多いのですが
中心的になってアクティブに
活動している人は80代なんです
ここはインターネット上で
自主運営の老人クラブです
ですから事務所も地べたにはなくて
クラウドの上にあると
それから月に200円ずつ
会員さんから頂く会費で
経費はまかないますので
役所や企業等から補助金とか
寄付金とか頂いておりません
それからもうひとつ
レンタルサーバーの上に
システムを構築しているのですが
そのシステムの構築運営も
全部自前でやっております
それともうひとつ
メロウ倶楽部は
高齢の方の集まりですから
車椅子から降りられない方も
たくさんいらっしゃいますし
さらに自分が動けても
ご家庭で介護をして
おられる方がいます
家から一歩も出なくても
メロウ倶楽部のサービスが
全部楽しめるということが
基本になっております
ですから今 あっちこっちで
年次総会というものを
団体でやってますよね
だけどメロウ倶楽部では
一切それを
インターネット上でやって
インターネット上に議案を提示して
討論をして頂いて
質疑応答があって
さらに電子投票で
採決はしております
お互いに厚い信頼関係で
結ばれているから
こういうことができるんだと
思うんです
ならばその厚い信頼関係の
元は何か
ということについて
お話ししたいと思います
これにつきましては
ひとつには会議システム
というものを
使っているのですが
これは先輩の話では
昔フランスにサロン
というものがあって
文化人とか小説家とか
絵描きさんとか音楽家が
貴族のサロンというか
応接間に集まって
知的な会話を交わしました
また日本でも
夏目漱石さんは
自分のお弟子さんと
似たようなことを
やっておられました
そういうようなサロンを
インターネット上に再現したい
とういことで こういうものを
始められたとういう話は
聞いております
まあそんなことで
どうしてそれが
いいのかと言いますと
メロウ倶楽部ではもちろん
写真投稿サイト等と違いまして
文章でいくんですね
文章のやりとり
文は人なりなんです
だからその人の書いていることを
縷々（るる）読むと その人の人柄が
私に全部 ジーンと伝わってきます
とういうようなことで
色々な会議室を作って
楽しんでおります
で 一番老人会である故は
「生・老」とういう部屋が
あるのですが
私達ハイシニアというのは
近い将来 体力が衰えて
病気になって死ぬという
予定の上で暮らしています
人間いかに生老病死と対峙していくか
こういうことについて語りあうのは
やはりここだと思っています
この方も本当に やっとという時に
「これが最後の投稿になるかも」
「長い間付き合ってくれてありがとう」
と言って去っていかれた方です
こんな風な付き合いでした
とはいえ
時々は楽しい全国オフと称して
全国大会もやりますし
部活みたいな同好会もあって
それなりの活動をするとか
あるいは地域の方々が集まって
勉強会やリクリエーション大会なども
やっております
それから交際交流も
大事なプロジェクトでして
日韓交流というのは16年間
ずっとやっております
普段はスカイプチャットを
やっておりまして
年に１回は全員集まって
合宿をやっております
先週も伊豆長岡で
２泊３日の合宿をやってきました
日本と韓国の間には
色々難しい問題があるのは
両方とも承知しているんですけど
我々シニアはシニア同士
草の根文化交流を
続けていこうではないか
ということで続けております
それから社会貢献というのも
やらなければいけない
その中で一番力を入れているのは
「メロウ伝承館」です
これは私達80代の人間というのは
戦前戦中戦後を生き抜いて
激動の時代を
生き抜いてきた人間なので
色々な体験をしている
その体験を後世に引き継いでいって
又若い方には歴史を学んで頂きたい
そもすれば歴史の襞に隠れがちな
普通の人の暮らしを
伝えていきたい
そんな活動もしております
そういうことの源泉になっているのが
さっきお話ししたお友達パワーです
とにかくシニアといいますと
例えば認知症の患者が
何百万人だ？いや
300万人じゃない 600万人だとか
それから介護にかかっている
費用が何兆円とか
そういうネガティブな情報が
どんどんどんどん
伝わっていっております
それは事実ですけれども
だけど中にはこうやって
自立し社会参加し
社会貢献をしている人
又そうしようと思っているシニアが
沢山いるんです
若い方々には是非それを
知って頂きたいと思います
とは言ったって
理想と現実の間には
ギャップがあります
しかしこのギャップというのは
根気よく少しずつ埋めていくしか
ないものだと思っております
本日は本当に大切なお話をする機会を
与えて頂きまして
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）